a little bit of a downer but we want to
bring it up we lost Leslie Jordan today
and I I can't not do you want to express
any any feelings about it I was
fortunate enough to interview Leslie
during the pandemic for something and
and it was my first time getting to to
really meet him and I grew up on a lot
of Leslie's comedy and the sitcoms and
he he made great Tick Tock videos
towards the end and someone like Leslie
when you say that he passed I feel that
but look Leslie made me happy Leslie
made millions of people happy and at the
end of the day that is the biggest
Legacy that one can leave so God bless
you Leslie and thank you I get no kick
from champagne
let's talk Buble night what was it like
with the music and the sounds you know
what I love Michael Buble and I said in
my package what a dope guy he is and
what a Timeless artist and I have to say
also one of the kindest guys in
Hollywood and that voice so to be able
to dance to his music and to have him
here what a what a great guy
um am I allowed to ask where Whitney is
she's not with us yes Whitney is
actually backstage talk about we've had
quite the week man it was the week of we
had the double shows and then
everybody's exhausted because we were
exhausted um I caught a bug and I got
sick then she went to Mexico for the gig
that I was going to then her kid gets
sick and has a super high fever we're at
rehearsal I'm passed out for two and a
half days so I don't get to rehearse
until Friday night she then their whole
family is ill then we finally get here
as we're rehearsing I kicked her in her
ankle I accidentally and right before we
go on she's laying with ice on her on
her legs so it was just like come on
bring it bring it what's next and we
still got the job done
we still showed up and Whitney is that's
my girl she's a trooper man oh man I
love that and I love even more that
Buble gives you a 10.
that was so sweet
yeah like him giving you I didn't feel
like we deserved a 10 but I feel that
you know when you have a guy like
Michael he also is the standing for the
audience and the audience is like we
don't care that that whole end of the
routine was messed up we love you ten oh
so that's what this show is also about
it's not just the dancing competition it
really is a human competition and that's
a lesson I've learned since I've been on
it and you really started rehearsing
Friday for this thing Friday night not
even is that possible not not even
Friday at eight in the morning Friday at
eight at night eight to ten think about
eight to ten I believe you and I'm
staring right now and and went to sleep
got back up and then nine two nine to
twelve or one o'clock then Sunday we
were camera blocking and then today hey
America vote for me
hey look who's feeling great
yes how are you doing you okay good yes
yes
um we just had a little incident before
we went on stage where yeah I told him
okay then yeah I just was trying to rest
and just take care of it you know before
coming out here but it all is well
hopefully we're gonna get you back next
week right yes for sure nothing's gonna
stop me oh back back oh yeah
um how'd you like Buble night what'd you
think of it before I let you run away I
am such a big fan of Michael Buble so
the fact that he was here judging we
were dancing to all of his songs it was
so beautiful
I was like this is a concert right now
Michael Buble was the best Whitney your
BFF Lindsay is expecting baby number two
congratulations are you excited oh I'm
so excited she is amazing she's an
amazing mom and so the fact that she's
gonna have another one is so I'm so
happy for them yes
[Music]